- [Gary] Tuesday morning.
I just had a really productive
VaynerSports meeting off camera
and I'm headed
back to New York City.
Bunch of meetings.
Then I'm going to go to
the Rangers playoff
game with Brandon Steiner.
And, get some work done.
("Unstoppable" by This Is Wolff)
("Eleven:11" by Pell)
Yeah, I mean,
as you can imagine,
there's so many
themes there that are similar
to what's going on in the
consumer packaged goods space.
I think, when I see
98% decline of growth
in the entire category
of Fortune 500 CPGs in 2017,
there is some real,
real, missteps on the way
that big brands are
spending media on above the line
and specifically digital.
Like (censored),
one of the
things that scares me,
is when a client
comes to me and says,
"Great news! We're
58% digital now."
When I know
90% of that 58
is going to be pushed
toward programmatic banners
and prerolls that not
a single person on Earth
is going to give a crap about.
("Wild Were The Waves"
by Signal Hill)
- [Gary] Boy, I really
don't want to do that
so let's figure out how to like
minimize that dollar amount.
Ya know?
Yep, but, I'm, yeah,
Dot, I'm on board with you.
Now let them get it down to
like (censored) by operating
the business for the rest of
the year and fulfilling what our
obligations with free stuff.
You know what I mean?
Like, there's a way to
drive that number down.
("Eleven:11" by Pell)
- [Man] What's up, Gary?
- [Gary] Hey guys.
You can be running it
against fucking (censored)
fan girls 22 to 29 because,
it's so funny I was about to
say what I think I would say
to a corporate client because
you're making the investment
on (censored)
I just don't think
I'm going to see it.
Give me the dollars.
- [Man 2] We'll go back and say
these are the three areas,
he's how much
money we have to spend.
- [Gary] Yes.
- [Man] And you guys thought...
- [Gary] 100%.
Alright.
- [Man] Peace.
- [Gary] Good to see you.
(crosstalk)
Fast. Fast.
- [Gary] How you been?
- [Man 3] Very good.
- [Gary] Good.
Good to see you guys.
- [Man 3] How is everything?
- [Gary] Really good, my friend.
How are you?
- [Man] Cool, I'm cool man.
- [Gary] Good, man.
Life is good?
- [Man 3] Life is good.
- [Gary] I mean, you know,
I just think that you guys
can do a lot for
him, for the brand.
I mean first of all I think
you're global, personally,
and I'm sure you guys
think so too, but listen,
they expect a gajillion
dollars to win in Africa.
I just think you've got a
real chance to do something.
So one of the biggest
things is distribution.
So, for example,
and you know this Tyler,
you're music on
Casey Neistat's blog,
like you take
seven vloggers on YouTube
and give them
original music consistently,
like we're making,
that Legendary song,
we made it popular.
We fucking made it popular.
- [Tyler] Yeah, it's
the opening for the NFL.
- [Gary] We made it popular.
People watch me and I only
have hundreds of thousands,
you get people with millions,
- [Man 4] Yeah.
- [Gary] You get a family in
Ohio that has 11 million people
watching them
every day vlogging,
and put your song in there,
it's like being on a
video game or a, you know?
In a commercial.
I mean, I think you
should put out music every day
on Soundcloud and
Spotify, every day.
Now, I don't know you,
I don't know your music process,
but there's not a song you make
that shouldn't see the world.
You're being too critical of it.
Let the market decide.
- [Man 3] Yeah, true.
- You're not going to
make anything disgustingly bad.
It may not be up to
your own personal standard,
but I know for a fact,
that you've had
songs that were way bigger
than you thought
they were going to be,
and you've had
songs that you thought
were going to change your
career and it didn't happen.
- [Man 3] Yeah, didn't do it.
- [Gary] I do it
every day. Right?
I have videos and
I'm like, this is it.
Hundred million on Facebook,
eh, and other things like,
What? Why is this
at a million already?
Got it?
- [Man 6] We'll
see Jason about this.
- [Gary] You are? I love it.
Let me do a quick picture
with you in the background
and give you some love.
I'll see you soon.
I'll see you then.
We'll talk a lot more there.
I definitely I'd
like to make two videos
at a hundred,
hundred fifteen each like,
that's what I'd like to do.
Here's what I like about it.
It probably won't work.
If it does, we're
forever associated with it,
and it's a win of all, like,
I don't like playing safe.
Let's go for it.
It's a trend.
("Wild Were The Waves"
by Signal Hill)
- [Gary] Hey guys.
Taking some of my own advice
that I've been giving you guys,
to, was that the
Apple Store, Avi?
- [Avi] No, Essential.
- [Gary] This one right
here, it used to be, right?
- [Avi] No, it's up
here on the corner.
Oh, okay.
Anyway, taking
some of my own advice,
I just came out
of meeting with a guy
who I'm not doing
business with actively,
but I have in the past,
who is just ridiculously
smart and punchline being,
I'm going to be spending
time with people that
I see myself spending
time with 30 years from now.
And so I'm starting to allocate
more and more time on that.
I also, right before that,
met with a former employee.
Once in Vayner,
always in Vayner.
Former employees,
if you see this, hit me up.
So, just trucking along
my day, but big punchline is,
you need to continue to hack,
you know I kind
of talk about like,
add a winning friend,
cut a losing friend.
It also comes to your calendar.
Try to add one more meeting
with somebody that you think
you're going to be in
friendship or in business with
in 30 years,
especially if you can have both.
It's just smart.
And so I'm trying to triple
down and go a little bit deeper
on some of these
seven to ten winners
and one to three super winners
and so I'm really
focused more than ever on that.
(fans cheering)